max what's going on here yeah those four
things in a row don't sound good do they
so you know only a couple years ago
Meredith Whitney was a true star I mean
Wall Street at the end of the day
doesn't have that that many stars that
sort of people really know and they are
female stars for that matter let alone
female stars absolutely hedge funds I
mean there you can count on your hand
how many significant hedge fund managers
there are it's incredibly tilted yeah so
people I think it's fair to say in some
ways we're really pulling for Meredith
Whitney and over the last few months
sort of all the things that that you
don't want to see happen at your hedge
fund have happened to be fair on the one
hand it's been a really hard year for
hedge funds across the board but
Meredith Whitney's hedge fund which is
called kenne bell capital and her fund
is called american revival fund they
have had some pretty nasty things go on
like their biggest investor who's tied
to a billionaire named michael platt
they have asked for their money back and
the interesting thing is kendall capital
as far as we know has said no they don't
want to give the money back and then on
top of that they have major executives
leaving so it hasn't been pretty well I
think people were pulling for her but I
gotta tell you max there were a lot of
people gunning for her for her demise I
mean she really for lack of a better
word pissed a lot of people off with her
muni bankruptcy call I mean a lot of
people came on the phone with me and
were like who you know who the heck does
she thinks she is so she's you had
friends and enemies on Wall Street right
no that's fair actually when I first
came to Bloomberg News are just like
almost exactly four years ago I was I
remember I was watching TV on a Sunday
night and the 60 minutes came on and it
was on Meredith Whitney said on national
television there's going to be a spate
of municipal default so in other words
you know billions of dollars of towns
and cities in New York defaulting across
America I should say and people were
kind of freaked out at that that was a
scary thing this is everything and one
of my first stories for Bloomberg was
about how she was she sort of said when
when I asked her about it there was sort
of a guesstimate and I remember she said
something along the lines of like fifth
derivative dimensions have gone into her
calculus and she didn't have specific
math to back it up I remember was the
gist of a story right and so I think the
people were upset not only that Meredith
Whitney had should have predicted this
very dire prediction about America but
but that it turned out she didn't really
have sort of
specific things backing it up but an
interesting link between that and the
hedge fund is that American revival fund
was sort of it seemed that it was going
to be putting her theses in into the
market supplies right and that hurtin
that my sense was that she had this idea
that sort of you know so-called flyover
states right like Texas right Arkansas
that their economies were going to grow
faster than New York and California and
you know I think that in some cases that
that very well may be true but I guess
it's really hard to make specific bets
on on stocks on a big call like exactly
so in today's story I've written a
couple stories about Meredith for the
last few days but in today's story
ruined about a retailer called cons and
Texas which sells like appliances and
electronics on credit in the south and
it's been down I think something more
like done more than fifty percent i
think this year and and we wrote that
she's lost a couple million dollars on
it just based on that just on that alone
and it's not a huge fun so hard hard
days i guess